on l'apprenait mercredi nagui quitte
après 15 ans d'animation la célèbre
émission de france 2 tout le monde veut
prendre sa place
l'animateur a révélé dans le parisien en
avoir marre de présenter ce jeu et
qu'ils n'avaient pas assez évolué ces
dernières années
chose dont il avait fait part plusieurs
fois à la production depuis la première
émission c'est exactement la même donc
dès l'instant j'ai voulu apporter
quelques modifications sont pas été
possible sans les coproductions d'après
la production la nouvelle version du jeu
devrait être à l'antenne à partir du 9
août avec un nouveau présentateur et
avec cette case de 11h 12h qui réunit
chaque jour en moyenne 1,6 million
téléspectateurs
on peut dire que tout le monde veut
prendre sa place tout prendre alors
cyril féraud laurence boccolini olivier
minne
nous vous avons demandé dans tpm paix
qui vous voyez le plus lui succéder
heureusement collier 20% cyril féraud
50% olivier minne 30% voiliers ou pas
pour l'instant du côté de vent de rien
n'était arrêté
alors quel animateur pour remplacer
nagui dans tout le monde veut prendre sa
place si c'est le cas de stratégie quand
même et en face du roi du big bang est
loin loin devant ses trois millions cinq
cent mille nagui fait un million cinq
cent mille à peu près dans les
meilleures heures c'était deux millions
deux cent mille les épisodes avec d'agde
et seront diffusés jusqu'en juillet 2021
d'accord qui vous voyez vous à la place
de nagui
laurence boccolini laurent parce que
tout simplement c'est le choix
disons qu'ils aient le le pousser
premier choix de la chaîne pour
l'instant elle a déjà fait ses preuves
avec mot de passe et maintenant on va
essayer de voir si avoir une figure
féminine et en plus il connaît bien les
jeux télé bah ça peut marcher à cette
heure ci alors quand est ce que vous
c'est moi je vois plus beaucoup et
animatrice belge qui vont essayer de
faire venir en france pour l'énergie
pour faire face
pascal titi vieillotte
non france 2 va faire des pilotes dans
trois semaines avec notamment laurence
boccolini cyril féraud est aussi une
animatrice belge qu'ils vont tester en
france et on connaît pas encore le nom à
un voile a pris en excès sert qu'à
partir du 9 août
en tout cas il y aura la nouvelle
version l'émission va être un petit peu
reformater il y aura quelques
changements et elle reviendra sur le
domaine c'est celle là qui revient n'ya
pas une autre
et mon beau j'ai entendu qu'ils avaient
noté puisque il conserve le format est
une nouvelle création française parce
qu'aujourd'hui dans la logique de france
télévisions sont des créations et non
pas des adaptations et là tout le monde
veut prendre sa place est une si coco
rico une création française
ap arbres ils ont acheté un format
international on n'est pas une
contrariété près avec vous bernard
montiel passe comme et qu'elle est tout
le monde ça te prend la place de
toulouse alors vous casta dont moi qu'à
manger pas léger pas terminé c'est pas
cool cassant la conséquence talent déjà
donc en fait non alors que j'ai dit j'ai
serré mais ils m'ont proposé de
remplacer nagui ya quatre ou cinq ans
avant d'arriver c'est parce qu'ils
avaient déjà des ddd de ça vous irait
lui entre simone harari dégraisser
écouter à la plage à l'époque j'étais
vraiment au chômage je pense que
j'aurais dit oui surtout dû au carré ou
cash pour voir si ça le fait du haut
carré cash a super bien parce que vous
êtes du public
c'est gentil là bas moi je peux prendre
alors bush à vannes c'est moi je trouve
que cet essai un très bon choix mais je
pense que j'ai eu un peu petit pour lui
mais bon et vous si céline européen
choisir et ses riffs et rotman
semblerait que pour l'instant ce soit
donc le choix se faisait beaucoup de
salinité passerait correspond au choix
de la sélection
c'est une phase voilà y'a pas moins de
50 vous êtes une femme non à l'homme
blanc de moins de 50 ans et 50 ans donc
je remarque c'est tout